mesdames et mesdames et messieurs mes
chers amis c'est inconscient très
importante parce qu'au fond tout va
commencer par la refondation de l'europe
c'est la refondation de l'europe qui
nous donneront qui nous donnera des
marges pour poser les bases de la
''refondation'' de la france c'est dans
ce sens là que nous voulons poser le
problème
bien sûr je voudrais remercier pierre
lequiller françoise grosse tête
jean bizet franck proust constance le
grip brice hortefeux pierre lellouche
philippe juvin marie-louise damien
pourquoi c'est important parce que les
républicains je le dis à nos amis
italiens comme allemand nous sommes le
parti de l'europe mais pas de n'importe
quelle europe
isabelle le sait je veux la première
idée que je me posais oui à l'europe
mais pas n'importe quel ordre
nous devons être le parti d'une europe
profondément refonder et nous voulons
affirmer que les choses ne peuvent pas
rester dans l'état parce que j'ose le
mot
le projet européen a vieilli peut-on
dire ça sans être catalogué d'euros fob
oil inverse de robert le projet européen
a vieilli et je vous parle en européens
engagés et sans doute que la partie la
plus exaltante de ma vie politique
le moment où j'ai exercé la présidence
de l'union européenne
nous ne reconnaissons plus l'europe nous
la comprenons plus et nous ne pouvons
pas accepter que tant d'européens se
détournent de loeb sordo mini jeux je
veux dire que entre les europhobes wizo
lattre il ya les européens convaincus
qu'ils ne se reconnaissent plus dans le
projet européen
et c'est au nom de notre attachement à
l'europe que nous voulons refonder le
rhum c'est parce que nous sommes
européens que nous voulons poser les
bases d'une nouvelle europe est
d'ailleurs que les choses soient claires
l'europe a été mise en place dans les
années 50
l'europe a été refondée dans les années
90 avec la création de l'euro la
création de schengen nous sommes en 2016
nous devons poser les bases d'une
nouvelle refondations de l'europe ces
périodiques l'europe de de la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
n'avait rien à voir avec l'europe de
l'euro et jag m mais aujourd'hui il faut
poser les bases d'une nouvelle
refondation et nous disons que la
première étape de l'alternance
consistera pour la france à mettre sur
la table du conseil européen un nouveau
traité et là encore je dis à mes amis
allemande
ces propos on prend personne en traître
je veux l'occasion nous parler pourquoi
un nouveau traité parce que nous voulons
plus du replâtrage
donc il faut être cohérent
nous sommes européens donc nous voulons
une refondation
nous voulons une refondation donc nous
voulons de votre été c'est une cohérence
absolue et nous ne voulons plus que les
peuples se détournent de l'europe
regarder depuis 2008
crise financière crise économique crise
migratoire et demain peut-être crise
institutionnelle avec le
le break site donc on a la totale si
face à une crise financière une crise
économique une crise institutionnelle
une crise migratoire
on ne pose pas la question d'une
refondation du projet européen
je poserai la question quand aura-t-on
l'espace très réconfortant et d'ailleurs
qui est légitime pour le faire si ce
n'est la famille politique qui a
toujours mis l'europe au coeur de son
projet qu'un premier problème de
l'europe
je le dis à nos amis européens disons
les choses une crise du leadership
il ya plus de leadership et il ya plus
divers chip pourquoi parce que d'abord
je le dis tu connais mes liens avec
l'italie
moi quand je parle de l'amitié avec
l'italie j'ai quand même eu 12 et qu'il
y avait de mieux en italie moi je suis
pas simplement européen de deux réseaux
chan européen de coeur par ma famille et
mes et j'ai pas toujours plus pire ça
j'ai changé moi même disons les choses
comme elles sont l'europe sont le couple
franco allemand
ce n'est pas noble et tu sais juste pas
toujours cru ça j'ai pas toujours cru ça
je j'ai appris j'ai évolué j'ai vu j'ai
pensé qu'on pouvait remplacer le couple
franco-allemand vérité c'est une erreur
et c'est une erreur pourquoi parce que
si vous prenez l'italie et la france on
a pas l'histoire de deux que nous avons
avec les allemands depuis le xiv nous
sommes affrontés avec les allemands
jusqu'en 1945 tous les 30 ans écoutez
excusez moi si on tient pas compte de ça
si ça ça compte pas dans l'histoire
européenne c'est qu'on ne connaît pas
l'histoire
et c'est justement au nom de ces
affrontements brutaux successifs que je
me suis toujours interdit
de mettre du sel sur les plaies qu'il
pouvait y avoir entre la france et
l'allemagne
c'est trop grave c'est trop important on
ne joue pas avec ça on ne joue pas avec
l'anti germanisme d'une france où l'anti
france venus d'allemagne c'est trop
grave c'est trop important
l'europe a été fait pour ça pour
réconcilier
mes chers amis il ya des génies des
génies qui à un moment donné on dit
l'affrontement entre la france et
l'allemagne ça suffit nous n'en voulons
plus moi j'ai été élevé par mon
grand-père qui a fait la première guerre
mondiale qui a connu la seconde guerre
mondiale et je sais très bien comme on
appelait les allemands chez moi comme
dans tant de familles françaises et je
trouve irresponsable tout propos facile
qui consisterait à critiquer les
allemands à remettre en cause l'amitié
franco allemande
c'est trop grave chez nous alors il ya
des points de désaccord j'en ai eus avec
un biais là il ya des points de
divergence c'est normal mais ne jouons
pas avec ça nous les républicains le
couple franco allemand
l' axe franco allemand c'est essentiel
parce qu'il ya entre nous des millions
de morts alors on s'est affrontés avec
les anglais
écoutez un siècle et demi après c'est
l'entente cordiale bon mais ça n'a
jamais eu l'intensité
je veux dire dramatique a pris
l'affrontement du 20e siècle on ait des
divergences avec l'italie on a eu des
affrontements avec l'espagne nono de
napoléon mais voilà donc je veux bien
qu'on s'explique et que vous compreniez
cela jamais nous les républicains nous
ne renoncerons à notre idéal européen
parce que l'europe apporté deux choses
qui sont la paix et la démocratie gens
dire un mot parce que j'ai pas aimé
certains commentaires la paix la
démocratie la base de tout ça c'était la
réconciliation franco-allemande et nous
sommes du même continuer
puis je vous dire une chose dispersion
choqué personne
quand je suis en asie si vous saviez
comme nous européens quand je suis en
angleterre si vous savez comme je me
sens français
et quand je suis dans les territoires et
provinces de france si vous savez que je
me sens parisien voilà c'est c'est pas
du tout critiques des uns des autres
c'est simplement que on se rend compte
quand on est en europe qu'on n'ait pas
simplement de sa famille de son sens de
son sexe de sa nation on et de son
continent
mais moi je crois profondément continent
européen la civilisation européenne
faut-il d'ailleurs ne rien comprendre à
l'europe pour nier les racines
chrétiennes de l'europe
c'est consternant pourrait conseiller à
monsieur moscovici la lys la lecture de
certains livres la vue de certains films
la réflexion tout simplement donc en
l'europe
l'axé franco allemand et le chemin que
j'ai parcouru j'ai dit l'europe nous
apporter la paix l'europe apporté la
démocratie aide et je trouve une
arrogance tellement propre à nos zélites
quand elle juge ces élites la démocratie
chez certains de nos partenaires de
l'europe de l'est que je veux défendre
j'avais bien des désaccords avec les
frères kaczinsky il se trouve que je les
ai connus et que j'ai même négocier si
tu fais une fameuse bagarre fameuse nuit
avec les frères kaczinsky le traité de
lisbonne
enfin excusez moi quand ils ont perdu
les élections ils sont partis ce qui est
quand même la barque de la démocratie
j'ai des désaccords avec le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban
je rappelle qu'il a gagné trois fois les
élections qu'il a perdu une fois quand
il est apparu les parties qu'est ce
qu'on veut on préférait l'époque du mur
de berlin où 80 millions d'européens
étaient sous le joug communiste
il ya certainement des tas de désaccord
avec la pologne sur gouvernement avec la
hongrie son gouvernement mais j'affirme
que ce sont devenus des démocraties
en tout cas des démocraties incomparable
par rapport à ce qu'elle était à
l'époque du mur de berlin et des
communistes
maintenant dire ça sans être accusés de
s'aligner sur le premier ministre
hongrois ou ou nouveau gouvernement pour
le maire a écouté j'ai vu quantité de
gouvernement polonais qui se sont
succédé ce qui est bien la marque d'une
démocratie est d'ailleurs dans leur pays
sont contestés par qui par l'extrême
droite qu'est ce qu'on veut que l'europe
se coupe de vin que l'europe se couvre
de gouvernement d'extrême droite et donc
je n'aime pas les leçons qui sont donnés
à ces pays qui quand même sont arrivés à
la démocratie très récemment
pourquoi parce qu'une partie de l'europe
les avait une partie du monde les avait
abandonnés après yalta quand même il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont
parce que yalta c'est une négociation ou
une partie des européens se sont trouvés
du mauvais côté du mur
alors qu'on leur avait promis des
élections libres et en vérité au lieu
d'élection les bizots des chars
communistes des chars soviétiques à
l'époque et on a eu la division de
l'europe
donc l'europe nous apporter la paix et
nous apporter la démocratie aussi
imparfaite soit elle est d'ailleurs nous
mêmes nous avons bien des leçons à
recevoir des autres et nous devons me
semble-t-il nous éviter d'en donner aux
autres alors avec cette fois être lucide
et je le dis aux amis britanniques
je suis de toutes mes forces pour que la
grande bretagne reste en europe
que ce soit clair par écouter grâce à
monsieur hollande
les anglais sont passés devant nous
ça va pas durer et sont passés devant
nous sont passés devant nous c'est la
deuxième économie d'europe
tant mieux pour eux écoutez on va pas
donner le ridicule de se priver de se
séparer de la deuxième économie la plus
dynamique d'europe
au moment même où l'europe de nos
ridicules de négocier l'entrée de la
turquie
le grand chelem de l'erreur j'en serais
la sortie la grande bretagne il entraîne
la turquie là je dois dire que de ce
côté là on pourrait pas faire pire
mais briques site ou pas il faut la
refondation le monde et je suis de ceux
qui pensent qu'on a raté une occasion
beaucoup des demandes britannique david
cameron était légitime et nous aurions
bien mieux fait d'écouter ses demandes
pour à froid est ce que je me fais
comprendre à froid pour tranquillement
dire va regarder podemos en espagne
regardez ce qu'a fait un clone en italie
regardez la grèce avec un gouvernement
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche
regardez vienne vienne
mais pour moi pardon par les émotions
mais pour moi viennent c'était la
capitale culturelle de l'europe dans les
années 30 40 et qu'est ce qu'elle donne
aujourd'hui bien qu'on appelait vienne
la rouge pardon et donne aujourd'hui 30
6% pour l'extrême-droite 11% pour les
parties gouvernement donc pour moi le
bric site où le risque de brick site
doit être un encouragement une
opportunité oserais-je le mot de
refonder le projet européen et non pas
d'attendre comme les gaulois que le ciel
nous tombe sur la tête
il y avait beaucoup de demandes dans
lequel nous nous reconnaissons dans
lesquelles nous nous reconnaissons vue
d'angleterre il s'agit pas du tout c'est
un philippe jean françois boucher
constance de céder à des demandes
britanniques ça n'a aucun sens
il s'agit de dire le scepticisme du
peuple britannique ou de scepticisme de
tant d'autres peuples en europe doit
nous conduire à nourrir à réfléchir aux
réponses que nous devons apporter
changer l'europe donc que ce soit le in
ou le out
je souhaite de tout coeur que ce soit le
leuy mais même si c'est le in et surtout
si c'est lui il
on doit refonder l'europe parce que
penser que parce qu'ils auraient gagné
parce que david cameron vous auriez
gagné le référendum il ya plus de
problème est qu'on peut faire comme
avant serait une erreur majeure
je le dis comme je pense donc quoi qu'il
arrive
s'ils sortent d'europe il faudra toute
manière réparer les dégâts mais s'ils
restent dans l'europe il faudra
comprendre qu'on a eu chaud et que c'est
pas normal et que l'europe avait un
pouvoir d'attraction et que maintenant
c'est pas les forces anti puces chez les
forces centripètes qui triomphe
et donc il faut faire attention à cela
et donc il faut refonder l'europe
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça quel est
le contenu de cette refondation
naturellement je et puis quelle est la
méthode
bon alors le contenu c'est de la
refondation au pn c'est d'abord un
schengen 2 enfin écouter mes chers amis
l'afrique va passer en trente ans de 1
milliard d'habitants a admis à 300
millions dont 30 ans le troisième pays
le plus peuplé du monde derrière l'inde
et la chine sera nigeria la méditerranée
fait 800 km de large au plus haut plus
long il ya 780 km entre nice et et unis
je pourrais multiplier les exemples
la question de la politique migratoire
européenne est absolument centrale
si on veut bien réfléchir je crois avoir
été l'un des premiers mal m'en a pris
d'ailleurs à dire que schengen c'était
fini c'était le discours du printemps
tout le monde m'est tombé dessus à peu
près c'était un crime de lèse
gst eh bien depuis nous savons ce qui
s'est passé schengen s'est effondré donc
c'est même plus la peine de parler de
schengen
il n'y a pris de schengen est d'ailleurs
la première à l'avoir constaté ces gangs
et là lorsqu'elle a dit qu'il
appliquerait dublin ah bon très bien
mais comme schengen était censé
remplacer dublin si on applique de
nouveaux dublin sicafi jingan pardon je
sais c'est très simple ce que je dis non
20 c'est pas parce que c'est simple que
c'est faux il ya plus de schengen quand
j'ai dit qu'il fallait rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières
souvenez-vous que l'ineffable monsieur
valls précipiter pour dire que c'était
pas possible qu est-ce qui dit
maintenant il ya au moins dix frontières
européennes où les a rétablies y compris
les nôtres y compris lorsque j'ai
entendu le gouvernement allemand dire
qu'il faisait tellement confiance au
gouvernement français qui rétablissait
les frontières en alsace à la frontière
donc il n'ya plus de schengen il n'y en
a plus disons les choses comme elles
sont et d'ailleurs l'extraordinaire
c'est pâques schengen soit finie c'est
que c'est dur et si longtemps et je
regrette profondément qu on ait pas
réformer schengen encore une fois à
froid il ya trois ou quatre ans
tranquillement alors que maintenant on
doit tout rebâtir dans la pire des
situations
alors schengen 2 qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire prochainement
d'abord est-ce que vous considérez que
la politique migratoire est centrale en
europe
si vous considérez que oui excusez moi
ça peut pas être géré par un commissaire
européen
ça doit être gérée par un euro schengen
composé des ministres de l'intérieur
avec un président stable parce que la
politique migratoire européenne est un
acte profondément politique et c'est aux
ministres de l'intérieur européens
ensemble de gérer les frontières de
l'europe
première proposition 1 euro chengere
avec un président qu on a fait un
eurogroupe génomique pour l'euro parce
qu'on considérait que l'euro
c'était centrale on n'a pas dit
simplement il faut un commissaire
européen a fait un eurogroupe
on en reparlera pour schengen
il faut un euro schengen les ministres
de l'intérieur gérant la politique d
immigration pourquoi parce que je ne
crois pas à cette idée fausse d'un corps
européen de deux douaniers enfin si vous
imaginez la france acceptant que des
douaniers bulgare des douaniers anglais
ou des douaniers roumains viennent
contrôler nos frontières ça n'a aucun
sens on est dans la coopération
gouvernementale et je demande que ce
gouvernement de la politique cet euro
schengen se voit rattacher quoi frontex
frontex doit obéir à une autorité
politique c'est à dire au président de
roshan guen au président du groupe des
ministres de l'intérieur dirigé frontex
qui dérivent endex aujourd'hui qui
incarne la politique d'immigration
européenne
personne ne s'est pas je n'insulte
personne et je manque de respect à
personne je veux dire c'est un des 28 de
commissaires pouvoir que même les
commissaires ces puits de tout l'époque
où il y avait pour les grands pays 2
commissaire par pays et on en avait 9 ou
il y en a 28 on ne peut pas dire que
c'est un des 28 qui va gérer la à lui
tout seul la politique d'immigration
bon c'est la première proposition
la deux et de ce point de vue d'ailleurs
la crise de schengen est une opportunité
comme le pidgin guen c'est plus facile
de poser un nouveau single de la
deuxième chose que je voudrais affirmer
c'est que pour adhérer à schengen ou
jours schengen est exemplaire
on disait la roumanie la bulgarie je
m'étais opposé à la rentrée d'ailleurs
vous ne pouvez pas rentrer schengen un
parce que il ya de la corruption ou
parce que vous n'êtes pas assez
démocrates bien quel rapport avec la
politique d'immigration pour le 5
viennent d'eux pour adhérer au schengen
2 il faudra au préalable au préalable
adhérer à une politique d'immigration
européenne comme
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire par
exemple qu'il n'y pas question pour nous
d'abaisser nos frontières avec nos
voisins
si le montant des allocations sociales
donnés aux étrangers n'est pas le même
d'un côté de la frontière et de l'autre
sinon la dune dumping social avec un
tourisme social
c'est quand même pas difficile de
comprendre que si on veut abaisser les
frontières entre nous ce qui est tout à
fait juste ça m'avait valu peut-être
vous en souvenez vous c'était arrivé en
espagne zapatero à l'époque je n'ai bien
d'ailleurs avait dit je salue l'arrivée
du nouveau leader de l'opposition
espagnole
merci mais quand tu a régularisé 90
mille immigrés en situation régulière en
espagne de les envoyer en france puisque
comme les allocations sociales sont plus
importantes en france qu'en espagne donc
j'affirme que pour je suis d'accord avec
le principe d'abaissement des frontières
entre nous mais à législation égal sinon
on crée les conditions
naturellement d'un déséquilibre
phénoménal qui ne peut pas fonctionner
qui n'est pas acceptable
donc un gouvernement une même politique
je veux d'ailleurs signalé où est il
écrit que la liberté de circulation des
communautaires pour laquelle je suis et
je ne souhaite pas qu'on le mettre un
terme à cela mais la liberté de
circulation des européens en europe ne
signifie pas la liberté de circulation
en europe de tous ceux qui ne sont pas
européens
sinon pourquoi avoir fait l'europe si
c'est la même chose être européen ou pas
européen
donc on peut parfaitement affirmé que la
liberté de circulation nous y tenons
mais la liberté de circulation des
européens ne veut pas dire la liberté de
circulation des données européen en
europe
je voudrais proposer dans une troisième
chose dans le contexte est le nôtre
comme d'ailleurs il travaille les
gouvernements britannique et allemand
j'affirme la nécessité de mieux
contrôler l'attribution des aides
sociales aux étrangers y compris ceux
issus d'un état membre de l'union
européenne
un étranger tout juste arrivé en france
ne doit pas pouvoir bénéficier de
prestations sociales financées par
l'impôt de paix
ceux qui résident en france de longue
date eh bien je demande un délai de cinq
ans de résidence avant de pouvoir
bénéficier d'une prestation sociale nos
contrées beaucoup
isabelle il va de soi que si ces
contributif il est absolument hors de
question
si vous payez les cotisations vous avez
le droit aux prestations naturellement
il est absolument inacceptable
vous voyez que petit à petit j'ajoute
que je ne vois pas comment on peut faire
un schengen 200 se mettent d'accord sur
la liste des pays sûrs c'est-à-dire les
pays dans lesquels une demande d'asile
politique sera systématiquement refusées
et là on a ce spectacle extravagant mon
pauvre pierre extravagants pour toi qui
est un européen tellement convaincu de
l'europe qui décident de l'ouverture du
chapitre monétaire de l'entrée de la
turquie alors même qu'elle n'a pas mis
la même europe la turquie sur la liste
des pays sûrs nous discutons donc de
l'entrée de la turquie en europe alors
même que la turquie n'a pas été mis sur
la liste des pays sûrs at on déjà vu un
exemple une incohérence penser ce qu'on
veut sur le fond mais c'est d'une
incohérence totale
j'ajoute un dernier point qui est jean
dominique je suis sûr va le comprendre
l'europe c'est un système x ordinaire
est un club formidable c'est assez
compliqué pour y rentrer et puis vous
voulez pas en sortir
j'aimerais que j'ai loupé un épisode
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique comment on
exclut un pays d'europe où comment on en
sort tout cas je n'ai jamais vu dans
aucun traité je demande que dans
schengen 2 soit mise
une clause qui serait une première en
europe
une clause de suspension de schengen
d'un pays qui ne seraient pas ses
responsabilités
regardez après coup thierry georges
on peut parfaitement si un chemin pour
andré doit y avoir un sommet pour sortir
ou alors voilà on considère qu'une fois
qu'on a eu peur de rentrer et on a vu
avec la grèce ce qui s'est passé à
bombay c'est un billet aller et puis y'a
pas de retour
ça ne va pas deuxième élément du traité
la zone euro alors d'abord j'ai pas si
mes amis européens avec d'accord mais
d'abord il faut quand même prendre en
compte qu'aujourd'hui il ya pas une
europe y en a deux et que si on est pas
alors je dis pas qu'ils aient une robe
de la première division en europe la
seconde division je ne dis pas qu'il ya
une europe du premier cercle une europe
du second cercle pas du tout je dis
qu'il ya deux europe une europe qui a la
même monnaie et une europe qui a pas la
même monnaie nos amis anglais sont dans
l'europe 28
nous nous sommes dans l'europe 19,6 dans
mais si on ne on n'accepte pas de
reconnaître qu'il ya vraiment deux
europe qui ont besoin de deux politiques
différentes
je vois pas pourquoi on a accepté l'idée
qu'on pouvait être dans l'euro et
pendant longtemps la première europe
c'est l'europe de l'euro depuis la crise
de 2008 nous avons pris des mesures qui
s'imposaient je voudrais quand même
rappeler plan d' aide à la grèce plan
d'aidé à l'irlande plan daide portugal
pour éviter la faillite
la création du fonds européen de
stabilité financière pluie de ce que
nous avons appelé le mécanisme européen
de stabilité pour doter l'europe d'une
arme
financière depuis lors depuis lors
aucune initiative
si l'union bancaire adopté à
l'initiative de l'as baisieux mais c'est
tout est ce que les chefs d'état
gouvernement pense que tout est réglé à
ça m'intéresse parce que j'aimerais bien
discuter avec eux et notamment de la
politique monétaire
le patron de la banque centrale je le
soutiens et je crois me rappeler même
qui avait proposé son nom à l'époque m'a
valu quelques soucis avec mon amie
allemande puisque j'avais été assez
rapide dans la candidature je le
regrette nullement mais nullement parce
qu' il y aux moyens oui mais la
politique monétaire du quantitative
easing
excusez moi ça ne pourra pas durer
définitivement
pourquoi parce que pour faire simple
c'est une politique qui consiste à
déconnecter la création de monnaie de la
création de richesse jusqu'à présent
dans l'orthodoxie économique ont créé
autant de monnaie que de richesse
puisque vous un peu plus de l'inflation
pour permettre la monette devait
permettre d'échanger les richesses
maintenant c'est complètement déconnecté
donc c'est bien pour doper l'économie
mais si on croit que c'est la politique
monétaire que la pouvoir résoudre les
problèmes économiques de l'europe
on se trompe complètement cette quantité
de bonnet va s'investir dans des
endroits qu'on maîtrise pas créé des
bulles spéculatives et les bulles
spéculatives et zone caractéristique
c'est qu'elle explose donc je ne dis pas
qu'il faut l'arrêter du tout je dis
simplement qu'il faudra penser à un
moment donné à résoudre afin réduire la
voilure est allé un peu moins vite parce
que les mêmes causes produisant les
mêmes effets la quantité de monnaie qui
ne correspond pas à la richesse créée
près de la spéculation de la spéculation
et non plus de l'inflation puisque vous
avez observé comme s'est plu crée de
l'inflation pour une raison qui est
d'ailleurs assez simple c'est que la
concurrence est telle que les prix sont
tirés vers le bas
donc au lieu de l'inflation on a de la
spéculation et la spéculation qu'elle
soit dans l'immobilier dans internet ou
dans tel ou tel secteur à jour elle
explose
ça vous donne quelque chose comme la
crise que nous avons eu en 2008
alors là je demande qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout du gouvernement économique
ça veut dire un président stable de leur
groupe
un secrétaire générale de leur groupe
qui serait de mon point de vue le
directeur du trésor
car c'est quand même invraisemblable on
a une monnaie unique
on a une banque centrale n'a pas
directeur du trésor connaissez-vous un
pays où il ya une banque et pas de
directeur du trésor qui gère les
problèmes monétaires quel directeur du
trésor
il y en a pas et je veux dire là aussi
que l'allemagne et la france faisant 50%
du pipe de la zone euro qui ne paraît
pas insensé que l'allemagne et la france
joue un rôle dans la zone euro
particulier est entendue amis italiens
que pour moi le leadership n'est pas un
droit c'est un devoir
je ne dis pas que les grands pays en
plus de droits que les autres jeux dès
qu'ils ont plus de devoirs et quand ça a
commencé à souffler en 2008
on n'a pas été chercher le luxembourg on
n'a pas été chercher malte on n'a pas
été chercher chip
je sais qu'ils on a été chercher d'abord
et c'était normal
j'ajoute que le mécanisme de stabilité
monétaire que nous avons créé françoise
il faut le changer et je demande la
création avec les républicains d'un
fonds monétaire européen
et pardon de dire ça fera peut-être pas
plaisir à tout le monde mais je veux
dire mes convictions je ne comprends
toujours pas pourquoi le fmi s'occupe de
la gestion des problèmes monétaires de
l'europe
je suis très attaché mais attachés à
l'amitié avec
les états unis vous le savez même été
tellement attaqué pour ça je suis très
attaché au partenariat atlantique
enfin l'europe c'est pas une contrée
lointaine de sous développés enfin je
veux dire c'est très sympathique
nos amis américains est un avis sur la
grèce mais à mon avis la grèce c'est
dans l'union européenne
c'est à nous traiter de sujets et à
personne d'autre et compte tenu du poids
spécifique
excusez-moi des états unis dans le fmi
je veux un fonds monétaire européen avec
un directeur du trésor européens avec un
gouvernement économique de la zone euro
et un président stable qui gère les
problèmes de la zone euro
il me semble que c'est bon alors on peut
à juste titre me faire ce reproche
chez moi je suis passionné mais passer
des choses qui m'intéressent comme vous
dire mais tu l'a acceptée oui c'est vrai
j'ai accepté un moment quand dieu la
crise terrible
nous n'avions pas de mécanisme de
stabilité était un fameux sujet de
convaincre nos amis allemands
à l'époque il y avait des élections
c'était tout compliquer sa série glee un
dimanche une discussion toujours animé
très amicale nous n'avions pas même
l'idée même du gouvernement économique
souviens-toi suscite un débat maintenant
ça y est très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on veut une europe
indépendante en europe dépendantes
je vais l'ong indépendante et un des
flops y compris de nos partenaires
américains qui sont nos alliés qui sont
nos amis ne s'agit absolument pas de
plaider pour ne tenir
il s'agit simplement d'être indépendant
et naturellement tout ceci doit nous
conduire une coordination de la
politique économique
certains ont parlé d'un parlement
européenne la zone euro côté là
franchement on peut vouloir chercher les
ennuis après tout si on pose qu'on en a
pas assez
enfin on a déjà le parlement européen
qui est une réussite qui fonctionne on à
la commission européenne qu'il s'est
toujours pas rendu compte que puis de
1979 un parlement européen et qui
conduit consiste et qui continue à
produire des stations si en plus on fait
un parlement européen de la zone euro
non mais c'est qu'alors qu'on a rien
compris au problème de la zone euro en
revanche je le dis georget et pierre
parlementaires qui sont ici en revanche
il faut absolument associer les
parlements nationaux au gouvernement
économique sébastien de la zone euro
pourrait s'assurer de la coordination
voilà il me semble que si on fait ça on
change considérablement les choses
enfin dernier point l'europe des 28
alors là je veux dire deux choses qui me
tient à coeur
autant je crois à l'intégration et
renforcement de la coordination dans
l'europe des 19 euros de lots autant
pour lors des 28 e foire était donc ce
soir était là on n'en peut plus on ne
comprend plus rien il n'y a plus aucune
priorité
aucune politique l'europe des 28 doit
avoir comme première préoccupation de
faire fonctionner marché unique auquel
nous sommes attachés je crois tous et
quelques politiques majeures lesquels
pour nous français c'est italien le
petit grigol ça quand tu vois pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi au moment même où la
question de l'indépendance alimentaire
et la sécurité alimentaire est tellement
importante
on devrait céder aux intérêts de
l'agriculture américaine pourquoi je
pense qu'il faut une politique de la
concurrence totalement différente et tu
as raison du spectacle grotesque des
données aujourd'hui je comprends rien ou
plutôt je comprends trop bien je croyais
qu'il y avait un marché unique si un
marché unique les problèmes de
concurrence doit être analysé au regard
du marché unique pas au regard des 28
pays bas au regard des 20 du marché
vous prenez une entreprise comme edf
s'ils auraient eu des f au regard de la
france
exclusion est excessivement dominante
mais si vous prenez
edf au regard de l'europe c'est pas du
tout la même chose donc la politique de
concurrence européennes marche sur la
tête
empêche la constitution de grands
groupes européens j'affirme le mot
travail contre l'industrie européenne
et ça je peux pas l'accepter
politique commerciale politique
commerciale discussion la plus irréelle
qui s'occupe de la négociation
commerciale
un commissaire européen un des 28
je suis désolé la négociation
commerciale doit être dans les mains du
président de l'union à 28
qui doit les discuter d'égal à égal avec
le président chinois avec le président
indien où est le président des états
unis qui connaît les données de la
discussion sur le traité d'ouverture
avec avec l'amérique personne qui
connaît les données de la question de la
chine et de sa capacité à devenir une
économie de marché
ce qui veut dire par parenthèse la
suppression des droits de douane
personnes est ce qu'on peut avoir une
véritable politique commerciale en
europe qui est passé sur une chose très
simple la réciprocité
je prends la taxe carbone moi je suis
désolé je veux bien qu'on un conte
impose à nos industriels européens des
règles pour ne pas polluer le monde
mais dans ce cas là je souhaite une taxe
carbone aux frontières de l'europe pour
taxer les produits fabriqués dans des
pays où on ne respecte aucune des règles
environnementales qu'on impose à nos
industriels sait pas quand même pas très
difficile sur les ogm pluie même chose
je veux bien dans madame madame royal
dit qu'ils n'aiment rien tant que de se
faire filmer
on la voit dans un supermarché
et avec la bonhomie qui est la sienne
gentillesse s'exprime
évidemment dit voilà ce qu'il faut
consommer voilà ce qu'il faut pas
consommer parfait mais dans ce cas là si
c'est un problème pourquoi acceptez-vous
d'introduire en europe des produits eux
qui sont logés misé à fond venant
d'autres pays on peut pas imposer à nos
agriculteurs des règles et autoriser
l'importation de produits venant de pays
qui respectent aucune des règles de nos
agriculteurs sait pas quand même quelque
chose d'extraordinairement difficile à
comprendre donc donc politique
commerciale politique de concurrence
politique d'énergie
là on a va bonne discussion je suis
désolé c'est parce que je suis européen
parce qu'on est des amis que je vous met
les problèmes sur la table avec les
anglais nous avons choisi le nucléaire
c'est notre droit
je rappelle que la france est le pays en
europe produit le moins de gaz à effet
de serre gars grâce au nucléaire et pour
nos amis allemands ouvert les mines de
charbon
ils nous ont pas demandé si nous on
était contents de recevoir les
particules à paris aux coupes ou
ailleurs donc je dis comme je le pense
une politique d'énergie européenne digne
de ce nom
on peut parfaitement je peux
parfaitement comprendre ça qu'on les
différences ne peut pas continuer comme
ça j'ajoute que je crois aux énergies
alternatives
enfin la subvention près de 20 milliards
d'euros chez les allemands 1 milliard
d'euros qui tire les prix vers le bas
et qu'est ce que ça donne y'a plus de
recherche pourquoi puisqu'on peut plus
financer les prix sont trop bas donc il
ya un urgent besoin d'une politique
d'énergie européenne qui nous permette
de de discuter ensemble et de fixer des
priorités
bon je pourrais je pourrais prendre
d'autres exemples isabelle alzheimer
alzheimer est un drame
écoutez ya deux cent cinquante mille
personnes qui sont diagnostiqués et sa
mère parents pratiquement autant que le
concert pratiquement tout le concert
aujourd'hui la connaissance de la
maladie et damien très très faible on
sait que ce sont des plaques brune qui
se posent dans le cerveau j'avais moi
même fait un effort président un public
avec un plan de 300 millions d'euros
les scientifiques travaillent on n'a pas
trouvé bon mais l'idée qui est une
recherche française une recherche
italienne une recherche allemande aucun
sens mettons nous ensemble je pense ça
pour les mères je pense à pour le
concert et pourtant les maladies rares
les maladies orphelines
enfin il ya vraiment une europe de la
santé pour le coup jean a créé à porter
pour que les chercheurs d'europe se
mettent ensemble pour éradiquer ces
maladies épouvantable
sas a du sens en bon en revanche je veux
dire comme je le pense qu'on n'en peut
plus des actes d'exécution et qu'on n'en
peut plus des actes de gestion
c'est à dire les actes d'exécution un
acte de gestion
c'est à dire les arrêter et les
règlements que la commission prend sans
que les conseils des ministres au
courant sans que le parlement européen
sur le courant et ils vous sortent des
trucs invraisemblables alors ils ont
passé la courbe du concombre a été un
élément extrêmement important
l'huile qui assure l'étape 2 des
consommateurs allemands est formidable
la taille de la fraise
bon moi je ne fais pas une attaque
contre la commission c'est trop facile
je n'aime pas ça simplement les actes
d'exécution ne peuvent plus être pris
sans que les parlements nationaux soient
informés et puissent bloquer lors alors
les acquisitions c'est un peu pour
l'europe ce que les arrêtés sont en
france vous savez les parlementaires ne
savent bien
vous votez damien des lois et vous ayez
un monstre qui sort après sans qu'on
vous demande votre avis je propose que
pour les actes d'exécution les
parlements nationaux puissent bloquer et
que pour les actes délégués qui est un
accord exprès du parlement européen
voilà comme ça
si un problème c'est nous enfin je veux
dire nous les politiques qu'ils auront
laissé passer son responsable parce
qu'aujourd'hui on vous interroge et ont
découvert un acte de gestion option
extraordinaire
si vous avez moins de 16 ans z droit de
monter sur une échelle et que vous êtes
apprentis mais moins de trois barreaux
s'est trouvé un petit point pour parce
qu'à 4 barreau cedro dangereux voilà
enfin et là vraiment on aurait terminé
puis je dire un mot de d'une question
essentielle qui est l'avenir de l'europe
et son élargissement
je veux dire même si je suis minoritaire
que je crois inéluctable l'élargissement
de l'europe aux balkans et je me battrai
sur cette idée d'abord parce que les
balkans c'est l'europe et que mes chers
amis
ça nous a coûté cher dans le passé
lorsqu'on a laissé les balkans en dehors
d'une possibilité de règlement politique
en europe donc à leur rythme
tranquillement le moment venu moi
j'assume ce choix politique
je crois que leur place et en europe je
le dis compris pour les serbes
je pense est très important s'agissant
de la turquie je voudrais préciser les
choses moi je j'aime la turquie j'ai
très souvent été en turquie
et c'est un pays considérable en fait
ceux qui ne connaissent pas la turquie
parce que la turquie c'est les côtes
magnifique demi terrain n'est pas du
tout la turquie
sinon la cappadoce c'est l'incarnation
d'une civilisation à l'époque
troglodytes mais il n'est pas question
de gérer les affaires du monde sans la
turquie
je rappelle tout de même que j'avais
voulu que la turquie soit membre du g20
à ceux qui pensent que je ne connais pas
la turquie où je suis content la turquie
mais la turquie est en asie mineure
la turquie est un beau parent d'entre
elles à ce très grand un pont entre
l'asie et l'europe
si vous coupez un pont d'une de ses
rives
ce pont n'a plus aucune ci vise
utilisation utilité la turquie n'a pas à
choisir entre l'asie et l'europe la
turquie de rester un lien considérable
entre l'asie et l'europe et la place de
la turquie est pas non l'europe
à moins que vous vouliez expliqué aux
enfants européens pour la frontière de
l'europe c'est la syrie ce qui était un
projet intéressant mais je ne partage
pas tout à fait et je crois savez-vous
quand les négociations pour entrer la
turquie ont commencé 63 64 pierre un
moment il faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont on gagne à la franchise
qu'on ne gagne pas l'hypocrisie
j'avais d'ailleurs iter deux reprises à
ankara pour leur dire la place de la
turquie n'est pas aux normes quant à
cette idée insensée de supprimer les
visas pour 80 millions de turcs dans le
climat migratoires et sécuritaire de
l'europe
on se demande parfois si les gens
réfléchissent avec un minimum de bon
sens
pour moi donner des visas pour les
hommes d'affaires turcs donner des visas
pour des étudiants ont discuté il n'y a
pas de problème est que ça mais céder au
chantage de monsieur erdogan
spécialement maintenant au prétexte
qu'on a besoin des turcs
j'y reviendrai pour gérer l'une des
conséquences de l'effondrement de la
syrie c'est un chantage et vous pas
céder au chantage
je voudrais d'ailleurs dire tite a
augmenté le nombre de ceux avec qui je
pourrais me fâcher que l'ukraine qui est
un magnifique pays de 40 millions
d'habitants dont 30% de la population et
russophone le crâne et un pont entre
l'europe et la russie
si vous intégrez l'ukraine en europe
vous coupez le cren de ce rôle de pont
entre deux univers aussi important que
la russie et l'europe avec angela merkel
nous avions dit en 2008 ce maître du
terrestre que l'ukraine comme la géorgie
n'est pas vocation rentrer dans le temps
j'avais essuyé bien des critiques à
l'époque je vous rappelle que si on
avait accepté l'entrée de l'ukraine à
l'époque
dans le temps on se serait trouvé
embarqué au moment de la crimée dans une
nouvelle guerre qui celle-ci n'aurait
plus été une guerre froide mais un
véritable affrontement parce que compte
tenu des règles de l'otan quand l'un des
pays se trouvant guère les autres
doivent l'aider
vous imaginez que serait bien sûr
apaiser la situation
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça voilà
ma proposition la turquie n'a pas
vocation entre l europe
je ne crois pas que l'ukraine non plus
en revanche nous pouvons parfaitement
imaginer un nouvel ensemble indépendant
de l'europe qui rassemblerait la russie
l'europe et la turquie un ensemble avec
coopération politique à haut niveau
rêverie
sion sur une sécurité commune et
facilité des échanges économiques ce qui
ne veut pas dire naturellement marché
commun parce qu'un marché commun c'est
bien d'autres conséquences et nous
aurions ainsi un paysage sur notre
immense continent est un peu plus où le
premier élément le pull lâche dansez
dansez lien serait de près de 900
millions d'habitants russie europe
turquie pour parler sécurité pourparlers
politiques éventuellement pour parler
coopération économique
je reste convaincu que nous avons une
divergence de vues avec nos amis
américains sur la russie que la vocation
de l'europe et de la russie c'est
travaillent ensemble pas de s'opposer
nous ne voulons pas d'une guerre froide
ce qui ne veut pas dire naturellement
eric bien sûr que nous approuvons tout
ce que fait monsieur poutine et que nous
sommes d'accord avec tous en phase i
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
le grand ennemi le grand adversaire le
grand problème c'est poutine
alors qu'est ce qu'on doit dire de dèche
qu'est ce qu'on doit dire d'al qaïda et
de tous les dictateurs qui à travers le
monde terry's la planète comme le
dictateur de corée du nord avec ses
missiles et sa bombe atomique
donc nous voulons pas d'une guerre
froide nous voulons d'une collaboration
avec la russie ensuite j'aurai l'europe
des 28 tirs et vocation à devenir 30 ou
32 avec les balkans ensuite sur l europe
de l'euro car lé vocation à s'intégrer
voilà mes chers amis j'en ai terminé et
d'abord je veux encore une fois vous
remercier vous ici à cette tribune qui
est venue de pays européens qui nous
sont chères
merci pour votre français ensuite vous
ici et qui avait participé à cette
convention et vous dans la salle
vous avez bien compris les choses et
c'est vraiment ma conclusion l'europe
c'est tellement important pour nous que
nous refusons qu on nous empêche d'en
débattre
l'europe mérite le débat l'europe mérite
mieux que la caricature et moi je ne
pointe pas du doigt ceux qui parmi nos
je ne reconnais plus l'europe je veux au
contraire les convaincre qu'on change
les choses de l'intérieur et pas de
l'extérieur
voilà pourquoi ici il n'y a pas d'un
côté les souverainistes de l'autre les
européens il n'y a que des européens qui
sont convaincus qu'il faut inventer
pause et définir les bases d'une
nouvelle étape essentielle
merci à tous de votre participation
n'oubliez pas que nous proposerons aux
adhérents les républicains de s'exprimer
puisque l'europe mérite le débat nous
avons à peu près neuf questions à vous
poser qui vont en principe apparaître
sur l'écran
la première question selon vous quelle
est la principale cause de décrochage
entre les peuples et les institutions
européennes
l'élargissement trop rapide la
production des normes et des règles ou
l'incapacité de l'union européenne à
résoudre les grandes crises
deuxième question faut-il recentrer
l'union européenne sur ses missions
essentielles marché intérieur politique
agricole politique de concurrence
politique commerciale politique de
l'énergie et de la recherche
troisième question faudra-t-il que la
france prenne l'initiative d'un nouveau
traité de refondation européenne dès
l'été 2010 est quatrième question le
renforcement de la zone euro passe-t-il
par un véritable gouvernement économique
et un fonds monétaire européen
cinquième question face au dumping
social
faut-il intégrer le principe à travail
égal salaire égal sixième question
faut-il instaurer une condition de durée
de résidence minimale pour que les
étrangers nouveau venu en france
bénéficient dette sociale 7e question
faut-il rétablir les contrôles aux
frontières nationales
tant qu'un nouveau schengen n'aura pas
été décidée 8e question dans les
conditions actuelles la france doit-elle
s'opposer au projet de partenariat
transatlantique est neuvième et dernière
question les républicains doivent t'ils
réaffirmé que la turquie n'a pas
vocation à devenir membre de l'union
européenne merci à tous